ya hemos visto que el cambio en la
energía libre y que denotamos como delta
g verdad el cambio en la energía libre
se puede relacionar con el potencial de
celda e verdad y es a través de esta
ecuación lo mismo podemos decir cuando
estamos bajo condiciones estándar verdad
esto simplemente nos dice que el cambio
el cambio estándar en la energía libre
se relaciona con el potencial de self de
estándar a través de la misma ecuación
muy bien y esta ecuación que tenemos
aquí abajo es una ecuación que proviene
de la termodinámica y vamos a digamos a
poner estos valores justamente en la
ecuación de abajo para poder deducir
otra otra ecuación u otra expresión muy
bien así que vamos a hacer eso en vez de
delta g colocamos menos n efe
es igual a menos n efe es cero
rt por el logaritmo natural de q muy
bien y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
dividir de ambos lados
entre menos ene efe muy bien entonces
dividimos en de ambos lados entre menos
ene efe dividimos entre menos ene efe de
ambos lados muy bien y que es lo que
obtenemos lo que vamos a obtener es lo
siguiente bueno primero podemos decir
que estos valores se cancelan lo mismo
que el signo verdad y entonces bueno se
cancelan ahí y estos también se cancelan
cierto entonces qué es lo que obtenemos
del lado izquierdo tendremos simplemente
que es el potencial de celda verdad será
igual a es cero que es el potencial de
es el de estándar menos rt dividido
entre ene efe por el logaritmo natural
de q donde recordemos que q es el
cociente de reacción ya está a esta
expresión que hemos encontrado es a lo
que se le conoce como la ecuación de
next
y vamos a hablar de por qué es tan
importante la ecuación de nerds pero
digamos hacia el final del vídeo muy
bien ahora simplemente vamos a deducir
otra forma equivalente de la ecuación de
next ok y quizás debería decir que esta
forma que vamos a deducir es para cuando
estemos a 25 grados celsius muy bien
entonces pensemos que nos encontramos a
25 grados celsius y entonces la
temperatura la temperatura que tenemos
en esta expresión está dada en grados
kelvin muy bien así que tenemos que
convertir nuestros 25 grados celsius en
grados kelvin y para hacer eso
simplemente lo único que tenemos que
hacer es sumar verdad sólo tenemos que
sumar 273 verdad punto 15 para obtener
los grados kelvin entonces si si sumamos
273 punto 15 con 25 vamos a tener aquí
punto 15 aquí 18 que 19 y aquí 12 muy
bien entonces obtenemos 298 punto 15 y
ahora estamos con la temperatura express
en grados kelvin muy bien ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es sustituir los valores
de la expresión
rt / efe vamos express a sustituir esos
valores verdad para escribir una forma
distinta de la ecuación del ernst así
que cuando la temperatura es 298 punto
15 grados kelvin vamos vamos a
escribirlo así aunque tenemos 298 punto
15 grados kelvin verdad son grados
kelvin y ahora vamos a sustituir el
valor de r que es la constante de los
gases verdad que es 8.314 jules
divididos entre moles por kelvin muy
bien ese es el valor de la constante r y
ahora todo eso lo dividimos entre f
donde f recordemos que es la constante
de faraday muy bien y la constante de
faraday sabemos que es 96.500 verdad
esto es un redondeo 96.500
sobre muy simplemente recordemos que la
constante de parada y esencialmente nos
dice que cuál es la carga de un molde
electrones verdad así que vamos a
resolver esto verdad saquemos la
calculadora y simplemente calculamos
8.314 que multiplica a 298 punto 15 y
eso lo dividimos entre 90 y 6.500 muy
bien y la respuesta es 0 puntos 0 25 6 y
podemos redondear muy bien así que
escribamos 0 puntos 0 25 7 que esto será
aproximadamente será aproximadamente 0
puntos 0 25 7 verdad y ahora pensemos en
las unidades que nos quedan bueno por
acá los grados kelvin se cancelan ok los
moles también se cancelan y entonces nos
quedan jules entre colom y los giles
entre colom son exactamente
bolt así que en resumen digamos si
estamos a 25 grados celsius lo que es
equivalente a 298 punto 15 grados kelvin
tendremos la expresión de la ecuación en
hermes como que el que es el potencial
de celda será el potencial de celda
estándar menos esta expresión que es rt
sobre f que es lo que acabamos de
calcular que son 0 puntos 0 25 7 volts
dividido entre n verdad donde n es el
número de moles de electrones que están
siendo transferidos en nuestra reacción
redox verdad entonces eso va dividido
entre n por el logaritmo natural de cuba
donde q recordemos es nuestro cociente
de reacción así que esta es la expresión
digamos equivalente que tenemos para la
ecuación de en ernst a 25 grados celsius
y aquí está expresado digamos con
logaritmo natural verdad nosotros
podríamos convertir esto a logaritmo
digamos con base 10 en vez de el
logaritmo natural y podemos hacer esa
conversión de la siguiente
verdad simplemente tomamos 0.025 7 y
multiplicamos por el logaritmo natural
de 10 verdad así que saquemos la
calculadora para hacer esa operación
tendremos 0.025 7 que multiplica al
logaritmo natural de 10 y eso nos da
como resultado 0.05 917 vamos a
redondear lo como 0.05 92 entonces esto
nos da 0.05 92 muy bien así que
escribimos de nuevo la ecuación de en
ernst ok sería el potencial de celda
sería el potencial desde el de estándar
menos 0.05 92
volts verdad dividido entre n y ahora en
vez de hacerlo multiplicado por el
logaritmo natural de q sería por el
logaritmo base de 10 de q y ahora la
pregunta es por qué es tan importante en
la ecuación de nerds para que es útil y
es útil porque nos permite calcular el
potencial de celda bajo condiciones
digamos que no sean estándar verdad
condiciones de estado no estándares no
estándar perdón así que pensemos por
ejemplo en el potencial de celda si
pensamos en el potencial de celda
entonces podemos observar cómo es que
esto va a cambiar a medida que avance la
reacción verdad a medida que cambiemos
las concentraciones verdad porque el
cociente de reacción puede ser que esté
cambiando así que en realidad si
cambiamos las concentraciones estamos
cambiando también el potencial de celda
y veremos mucho más de esto en el
próximo vídeo así que yo creo que la
ecuación del mnr
digamos nos da mucha más intuición y más
sentido de este tipo de cambios y por
supuesto nos vamos a tener una mayor
practica un mayor intuición de esta
ecuación cuando hagamos más problemas y
tratemos de entender qué es lo que
significa